here to talk about everything that's
also going on in the nfl jeff one of our
favorite
um uh guests on this program
uh one of the hosts of the emmy
nominated daily program on nfl network
good morning football's kyle brant
congrats on that emmy nom sir
oh listen and the emmy for outstanding
studio host goes to rich eisen
no you're too good no you're awesome
both of us
are are blessed today so thank you i
appreciate you saying that and congrats
to you and the hard work and team that
just
churns out so much fun programming and
has turned into
must watch tv at the start of every day
on nfl network so
thanks bud because we don't we don't
have a shot to win that thing but it's a
hell of a job being nominated we
there we got a murderer's role we go up
against at sportscenter and pti and all
that we don't have a shot
but i love being nominated well you uh
yeah you're being humble
um you know and uh it's a big day
uh in terms of the studio host category
uh my money is on rachel nichols not
only because she's uh tremendous
and excellent what she does she is the
only uh
member of this list of nominated studio
hosts with hair
so it's a big day for the bald
brotherhood you see the world
differently yes i have
looked at that list i could have looked
at it for 50 years and i
never once would have considered the
follicular
talent of any of the hosts i hope the
voters don't though for your sake right
well you know also kyle maybe the reason
why
you don't look at the list the same way
that i do is you set
an nfl network first uh after all this
time i've i've been fortunate to do so
many things first but you have set a new
first for nfl network
which is to host a highly watched
program on the network
and also wind up uh having an article in
a muscle magazine
um that never happened for me kyle um
and and and you celebrated it by wearing
the rocking the new bengals jersey in a
in a hockey lease medium
which was i think a choice personally
but you may have the floor
i will see your 17 drafts hosted this
year and raised you
a blurb in muscle and fitness magazine
that that's what i'm bringing is that a
blurb i mean i i saw more than a blurb
man
it was cool it was very cool i'm 42 and
i got in shape
can we talk about real quickly kyle like
working out in the 11's is that a thing
that you normally do or was that just
for the photo shoot
chris you're all over me for this man i
mean i'm getting worn out by you first
of all
right now i was on him he makes the size
of the jersey joke there were many
remarks
on that that the cincinnati bengal sent
us a jersey that might have uh
been mislabeled and intended for k adams
because it was very small um and i told
i told chris that
i felt like uh mid 90s ron gant
amazing references amazing reference
yes um but no the 11
listen um it's uh it let's just say i
knew there might be some photographs
taking that day and i usually i'm
working out in some beat up old new
balances that i use to cut the grass but
on that day
the conchords as they say had to come
out come on muscle and fitness
i'm not knocking your hustle i am
celebrating you my friend
thanks my man the ad hocule of good
morning football kyle brent
you're on the rich eisen show oh man
well at any rate so
yeah um what it what what is what
catches your fancy in this draft
i mean it seems that uh we're past the
one and the two now and we're locked on
the three and then what happens at four
and
for me for me i i you know uh the
quarterback decision by the niners is
is fascinating but kyle pitts i can't i
mean he has had me at hello
um and you know uh lewis riddick said
earlier when he was on the show that we
all get drunk on height weight speed
athletes
um at this time of year and i told him
if if that's the case we've got the bed
spins man
uh you know i'm waking up the next day
trying to remember what the hell
happened last night with kyle pitts
i can't wait to see what happens with
him and the falcons at four that is
fascinating to me i'm with you i i left
uh i left my credit card open at the at
the bar
bridge they called me i i got the sims i
gotta i gotta find some denny's and some
grease because i am just so hungover on
kyle pitts i may have to have some hair
of the dog here's how drunk i am on it
rich
yes and this is this is my take on kyle
pitts and i'm not paid to be practical
it's fine
um i am dying for
san francisco to make history and take
kyle pitts now hear me out
i don't expect it i'm certainly not
predicting it however
and i know the price that they paid to
move up and i know it was an exorbitant
you would never do that if not for a
quarterback
if kyle shanahan took hold of an offense
that has
debo samuel kyle youscheck ayuk
garoppolo
and then as i'm calling the tight end
kittles and pits they would have the
number one offense in the league i think
kyle shanahan would be the ultimate mad
scientist
and as far as the price sure it's crazy
and it doesn't make sense and it goes
against all draft logic i understand
that
you cannot overpay for an all-pro player
if you would have told the the chief
that that's the price they had to pay
for travis kelsey back in the day
dust in the wind spend it it's worth it
i don't expect it
but it would bring the house down and i
think they would have the number one
offense of the league if they draft a
cow pit well not just the house of the
draft house it would bring this
particular studio house down kyle
because a couple weeks ago
a guy called in to the program and said
what if the niners trade up
you know they should keep garoppolo and
they could trade up and help
get him a wide receiver whatever and i i
asked him what was the most unwashed
item that he had
he revealed that he was what he dr he's
a food delivery driver is that what he
said at the time yeah he just traveled
and he said he wears the same sweatshirt
every day
um and i told him that he would have to
send it here to the studio and i would
consume a swatch of his material
if the niners drafted somebody other
than a quarterback third overall i mean
my heart just dropped with you even uh
putting that out as a supposition now
rich my recall is pretty good
yes i i seem to remember a couple years
back there was the same thing with you
consuming garments
and it had to do with ezekiel elliott's
holdout is that right yes saying that if
he did not start week one of the season
i would eat
mike deltufo's hat um and zeke did come
off of cabo
and then there was a whole big as you
would might say to do
yeah over the fact that maybe garrett
would not start
zeke in week one just to give him just
to get him in there
um you know slowly and thank god he
trotted out for the first snap of that
season uh but uh brockman is the only
one on the show who's actually eaten a
hat
because uh you said you would eat the
hat if the philadelphia eagles made the
playoffs a couple years ago because you
took mclovin twitter bait
which is very easy to take i did um and
as we all know uh wence and the eagles
made the playoffs that year
and um and so brockman's the only one in
the history of this i hope you have to
eat that sweatshirt
and if the niners shock the world and do
that i'm sure you can make something
out of it we could call it a grub rich
grub
there will be something where you eat it
and you hop off and do whatever you want
to do and we'll make it happen
you forgot the hashtag kyle but i
appreciate that
you know i gotta go viral we gotta go
viral or something kyle brandt here uh
on the rich eisen show uh all all that
said
um the the quarterbacks are are gonna go
we would think one two three and then
maybe four
uh what else fascinates you about this
draft kyle
stumble upon something this morning i
think is really interesting cincy at
five
there's there's a philosophical debate
that we're having
as it pertains to the cincinnati bengals
pick and it's uh it's kind of a
practical versus radical
if you are the bengals and you have joe
burrow who showed up yesterday in the
uniform release sporting the big knee
surgery scar in his knee yeah we saw
that
do you do the thing that is practical
which is
to take penn a sewer slater one of those
tackles
and protect him or do you do the thing
that's radical and take jamar chase
who is a prolific looking talent who's
going to grow old with him and they'll
have the offense to light it up
and if you indulge me rich i made a
comparison to my own home today and
exactly the same thing i did this on the
air
right now my wife and i are doing a bit
of spring cleaning i sprucing up the
house a little bit
and we've budgeted very tightly for what
we need to do we have some stone
steps that are off the front of our
house two or three steps but they've
fallen apart a very old house is kind of
corroded
we need to pay a mason who is a very
skilled craftsman to come and repair the
steps
my wife brooke wants us to do that she
wants us to spend this chunk of money on
that
i'm really resistant because that is the
pennies will pick it's practical
it's gonna help us it's not gonna really
make us enjoy it it's not a toy it's not
some cool new addition
because in the meantime i've got my eye
on this eighty inch television that i
wanna put in our basement
i really wanna put that down there i've
got the frame i've measured it i've seen
it at costco that's the one i want
that's jamar chase so it's do you spend
it on the steps which
that's not doing for just steps they're
fixed it's a great foundation for the
house moving forward
but boy that 80 inch hd oh my god it is
so exciting and i would have so much fun
on the weekends and i'm in a quandary
about what to do i feel like that's
where the bengals are well i
i would um i'm i'm going to tiptoe
into following this analogy kyle because
in this analogy you are painting your
lovely wife well i don't believe i've
ever met but i i'm
uh i i know you definitely are a family
man um
that you're painting the love of your
life as the mike brown
of the kyle brandt uh household um
which you know is rife with the issues
potentially sure
um i i would take that 80-inch
television set and i'll take that
80-inch television set
all the time i will take that 80 inch
television set i found the falcons right
now for kyle pitts i'm taking that 80
inch television
i wish rich i wish i could put you on
speaker i wish
i could play this back for my wife which
i will because
this has gone to twitter.com and they
are now
among bengals fans they're coming into
stairs or tv camps
and there's passion it takes out so i'm
glad you're part of the the 80 inch tv
army yes because
you know uh you can walk around the
steps i'm imagining right there's
a side entrance there's a side entrance
there's many different eyes it's got to
be that way
you could take a a flat board put it
over the steps for a while it might not
be that might not look pretty
but guess what when you're when you're
when you're scoring touchdowns
eventually you'll be able to pay for
those steps i would agree
my my wife brooke has presented that you
know people come to our home and our
our steps are broken down and you know
i'm like yeah but then
i'm going to take him down to the
basement and we're going to watch
dunkirk on 80 inches and their hair's
going to be blown back like the maxwell
tape guy
never mind the steps we need to step up
our tv that's what we
i'm passionate about this rick never
mind the steps how's that working how's
that surround sound argument working
oh the surround sounds ready the problem
is the surround sound
which i guess would sort of be the t
higgins in this equation
uh they that's already plugged in but
it's into this uh you know
terrible freight inch tv which will just
not do
right i need a much bigger screen if i'm
going to get my my christopher nolan
expertise and how i want it so listen i
hope they go tomorrow chase too
i just hope that you know the mail
carrier doesn't break an ankle coming up
our stairs ladies and gentlemen kyle
brennan
he wants the cue led rich he's done with
the the plasma
oh yeah we're moving on at rich
eisenhower twitter poll
should kyle brandt fix his front steps
buy the new tv all right we're in on it
too
please tell me and guys let's do the
right thing guys and girls tell me if
i'm wrong
tell me but you should see this tv it's
so
big it's incredibly clear whatever of
course it is i'm sure it's beautiful
it's great you can take the old tv and
use it as the ramp yes
how about that okay let's get into that
you take the old tv
should anybody have a gurney or a
wheelbarrow or you know if i'm if
the milkman is coming because it's 1952
you just wheel it right out my old 60
inch crash
not functional but it's you know
terribly functional but it works
[Laughter]
fantastic where are you going to be for
the draft what do you got what are you
doing i'm going to be
in the lower manhattan where we're not
going to
ohio uh we've been to philly been to
nashville we're not going to have peter
schrager representing good morning
football yes
any nominated again football yes he'll
be representing peter uh us in
cleveland but i'll be we're doing a show
like from our normal studio our normal
breakfast table in
in beautiful lower manhattan myself nate
and kay hey
kyle i want to thank you and everyone at
good morning football you've been doing
some beautiful
uh pieces and i know you're planning on
a support run rich run
yeah um you had a kid from saint jude on
last week and um
it means a lot and um tomorrow we're
going to announce what we've done for
run rich run this year went down this
weekend and it's pretty damn special and
i know you're going to be part of the
the uh promotion of it and i'd love to
come on and talk about it
and and do all of that stuff with you
and kay and and nate who also got
nominated and peter and everybody so
well rich listen we we we are people on
a hamster wheel in the nfl cycle and we
know that there's
there's kick off their season the super
bowl there's draft there's combine
listen part of that cycle is what you do
at the combine it's with what we set our
calendars to do it every single year and
it was missing this year and it wasn't
right that's part of what we do that is
uh
that is an ornament on our tree and we
need to have it so i'm glad you're
following up and i gotta tell you
i'm very intrigued about what you're
gonna announce because i don't know it
is
it's pretty special it's pretty wild
we've we've expanded the uh the idea
it's uh great
and no it'll be announced tomorrow and
then we'll talk a little bit more about
it when
when it when it gets out there um who's
on your pod this week
who do you got what's your latest uh
tomorrow i'm sitting down to record
uh with um april fool's provocateur
michael strahan
and uh fantastic we will talk
extensively i have uh brett favre
audio from a prior episode of ten
questions in which brett favre
in my opinion lies through his teeth
about giving michael strahan
the sac record so to speak and uh he is
has this story and he's sticking to it
saying he did not hand it to him i'm
going to play the audio for straight
hand and ask him to respond and talk
about what happened on that day well
long before uh what when uh when good
morning football was just a twinkle in
nfl network's eye
uh kyle yeah um warren sapp
called out strahan for giving favre the
sack record
okay or or favre giving strahan the sack
record okay
he called out farr for that and strahan
went at him
and we got um zap to call in
uh or doc you know appear via bucks cam
and
strahan via giants cam and did a sap
stray hand segment every week on
nfl network the two of them were amazing
and they would just go at it they would
go at it and then one time
jerome bettis we got him on steelers
game just to chime in and then the two
of them heaped
scorn on jerome about everything going
on in his world his life his hairline i
mean they went all in on everything
and stray stray is obviously um
you know at the forefront of literally
all that goes down
so tell him i said hello send my best
and
congrats on that pod everything that
you're you're doing with it and good
morning football and i appreciate the
time here
always great to be here with you guys uh
i can't see your congrats on the
emmy nominations and i cannot wait to
hear what's going on with run rich run i
appreciate that and i can't wait to hear
what happened was your steps in your
television set i'll keep you guys posted
i seriously that's a very important
stuff
send me the results of that poll and
people vote properly rock the vote let's
get
rock the vote hashtag you forgot the
hashtag
thank you very much kyle brown everybody
good morning football co-host
one of our favorites hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here